tu as entendu parler du portrait
chinois si tu étais un nazi serait quoi
comme nazi
[Musique]
elle est bonne
celle-làin bonne bonne je sais pas mais
ben je seraisman comme ça en me
suicidant j'aurais dit encore un juif de
moi c'était une
infermité une infirmité c'est quoi une
infirmité pité je
serais je suis déjà
aveugle je veux pas voir tout ce qui se
passe dans ce B monde ça tisole c'est
bien et si tu étais un
poison Cu Cu tout de suite tu penses à
ça des fois
non non je pense av bant à ça
pas trop quand même bon j'ai pas d'arme
laingway la seule arme que tu as chez
toi c'est une seringue quoi mais comme
tu la mets sur la table on pense pas que
tu t'en sers vraiment je m'en sers pas
ça m'a été donné par le père de Jane h
car la dernière seuls les officiers
blessés avaient droit à cette seringue
et une ampoule de morphine et et les
deuxème PPE il av droit de gueuler une
souffrance c'est vraiment faut briti ah
c'estuf tout ça ouais
perfidal un
accident Zepelin ah il est bien ouais le
henburg là le truc nazi qui s'est
scratché sur New
York c'était du rap avant l'heure et si
tu étais une
cicatrice B elle est interne la
cicatrice
ah j'ai reçu des coups de
cravaille ça se voit pas tu ch pour y
arriver avec G mais dans le
métier maintenant j'ai beaucoup de
bléoup je
r grand seigneur des derni grandig me du
19e claque tout dans les
hôtels pour pour voir les jets
privés tu t'es bien Maré finalement
attends j'ai pas
fini bah oui encore quelques bon coup
tir avec
bambou se marré avec Lulu fout de claque
dans la gueule c'est pasour il s fait un
champoing avec son
yaourt c'est le fil de son per et si tu
étais une perversion tu serais quoi
comme
perversion un pervers oui une perversion
je sais pas tu serais pédéraste
oui j'ai pensé pas une version c'est pas
une verion
tuess faut pas mourir idiot ça s pas
très bien passé quand même he tant que
tu étais actif ça allé mais le jour o tu
as été passif en je sais pas moi j'ai lu
ça dans dans Libération je l'ai pas
inventé c'est pas vrai c'est pas moi qui
bord l'oreille ah bant c'est ce que tu
disais pourtant dans le journal d'accord
c'était pas vrai je peux balancer ah
d'accord tu serais
zoophile pourant dans le même numéro de
ou ou bah oui non mais attends on dit
des trucs mon pote faut assumer après tu
es marrant toi tu disais quand tu étais
petit tu avais fait des choses à une
petite chienne quand tu avais 12 ans ou
je sais pas mais c'est vrai ou c'est pas
vrai maintenant il est rangé des
voitures il veut plus rien dire avec ton
petit
doigt ça s'est bien passé
tu es contente ta petite chienne
ou je même pas son n tu l'as
oublié tu serais pas copofage quand
mêmeas connuas
connu tu sais ce qu'il m'a raconté bah
vas-y non quand il était gamin ouais
gamin
non je jeune acteur déjà ave sa gueule
sa
tranche il avait pas de de il avait pas
de pognon ouais alors il va dans un
boxant il dit à mer Mael il dit je peux
pas tu peux
prendre tu as pas une poule pour moi si
tu vas tu vas il tu es déjà un
peu je te prête la pole làhaut il y a
deux avec toi ça te fait rien
ouais tu
parles pouit tirer à l'œil pu un jour il
il rentre il dit mais ça s la merde
écoute on va on va te je te jure
exivement on va te mettre dans le secret
il y en a qui y a qui en bouffe mais on
peut on a tellement de
demandes qu'on peut pas assurer alors on
met au frigoch réchauffe auain
Mar bien
allumé et un
supplice
supplice un r dans le cul ça c'est un
suppli chez chinois c'est comme
l'antiortrait chinois chinois fin
pas pour être s de rien raté debe
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu